and
I want to welcome everyone to this
preview of the SP Jane professional
certification in product management
we're going to be doing something
slightly different today but please give
me a moment to start our live stream
this process takes me about 30 seconds
appreciate your patience
all right
and we are now streaming live to
LinkedIn as well as YouTube and of
course on WebEx
um my name is Stuart Creek I'm with
simply learned I'm here with Arnold
bonnerjee who's product manager simply
learn for the SP Jane program and what
we're going to be doing today is um in
order to share with you some of the
thoughts from SP Jane's faculty we're
going to be playing a recording of a
preview that we originally
broadcast in August so
if you will
please
pay attention as we get this going and
let me know if there are any audio
issues
good evening and Welcome to our preview
of the professional certification in
product
spgn Global School of Global Management
my name is Stuart Creek I'm with simply
learn I am here
uh Dr Sullivan barnage
and Professor Nadia cyr are going to
help us introduce the program tell you a
bit about SPG
and and
my colleague Naman and I will talk a
little bit about simply learn and how to
enroll in the program
so to begin
um just recap
about spgn and about simply learn
talked about project management
how the program works gets you ready
for employment as a product manager and
the enrollment of steps and we'll take
your questions toward the end and put
those into the Q a box of your WebEx
window
so I'm going to turn it over to
Professor Dr Sullivan
to describe SP Jane and he has a few
slides that he's prepared I'll just
they had Dr Sullivan
thank you Stuart thanks a lot and good
evening good afternoon to it everyone
so let me just introduce myself uh my
name is selvan and I am the program
director for this particular program
from SP Jane
I bring about 35 years of Industry
experience
I have been in multiple roles be it
sales Quality Finance HR and head of a
global business as well managing profit
and loss
I've been teaching for many years I
would have trained about 10 000
Executives uh in my like in my corporate
life
so that's briefly my background it's a
pleasure to interact with all of you and
talk about this particular program
which I am anchoring with SP Jane and
just to introduce you about SP chain we
are a global uh MBA School B school and
uh in fact we started in Dubai our first
campus was in Dubai and then we went on
to set up our campuses in Sydney
Singapore and lastly Mumbai and there
are a couple of campuses which are
coming up one in London and one in the
US so we'll be having shortly two
additional campuses
you see some of our campuses out there
the one in Center is the Dubai campus
which we first started
and we have a lot of global recognitions
to just name a few I think as we can go
to the next slide
consistently we have been ranked by many
of the agencies uh in fact folks has
rated us from 2013 to 2021 among the top
20 in the world peace schools
and Times Higher Education for example
has been dating Us in 1819 as number
four best school in the world
so I'll not go through each of these
sort of acknowledgments which we have
got but just to let you know that we are
an Australian registered business school
and operating globally and therefore our
faculty are spread across all the
continents so you'll have faculty from
Europe you have faculty from uh India
from Singapore as well as from Australia
and they all have impeccable credentials
they are from our new Colonel just to
name a few of top of top large groups
they have graduated from uh to the 75
percent of them are three-fourths are
basically with doctoral degrees
and they come from five continents so
all this brings about a sort of
international flavor to the program that
you are going to go through from one of
the most acknowledged sort of b-schools
in the world so that's something which I
wanted to bring to your attention
through these slides that you are in
very safe hands with impeccable sort of
Faculty from across the globe and who
are all working most of the faculty have
Rich experience both in corporate life
as well as in Academia as you can see in
the last line they teach at NCR
University of Los Angeles
the Australian University in us and
Singapore all the famous universities
they teach so that's sort of Faculty
that we are bringing into this program
so it should be one of the very
interesting sort of
programs that we'll be going through
so as we go on to the next slide let me
request uh Stuart to take it forward
from here and explain simply learn who's
that partner in this program
go ahead
you're not Audible for me I'm not sure
about others
sorry about that but I then meet myself
one of those glitches that happens
um I just want to introduce you simply
learned very briefly we're the world's
number one online boot camp
um we have a scalable platform that it
has
to now reach uh about present 70k
monthly Learners we have we're a rope
leading completion rates compared to
other online types of
self-education
because we're a boot camp format that
professors from
institutions or
instructors
into the live virtual classroom
environment so that you're not just
learning from a pre-recorded videos
describe that a bit more
but um just wanted to say that we have
served over 4 million
across all of our programs
extremely excited to be working with
um
spga for the product management
professional certification
and
there is
what it says focused on digital skills
across the board so in addition to
digital marketing management type skills
we also offer programs and
technical skills software development
data science and across the range so
again
extremely proud and excited to be
working with SP Jane on this program
tell you a bit more about
product management
Dr Sullivan did you want to describe
this or shall I yeah sure so it's my
privilege to take these few slides and
explain I think most of you are here for
this purpose because I don't have to
really tell the importance of product
management because you all are
interested in this particular area and
that's why you are really here today but
just to reiterate I think uh today if I
talk to most of the uh b-school students
who might teach all of them have the
same query saying that how do I get into
product management as a career and that
seems to be the sort of interest that it
has brought in because it's such a
combination of almost all the sides of
management whether it is sales marketing
product roadmapping you you name it I
think the pricing strategies everything
uh it's bringing in everything together
and it's one of the key things that is
being sought after by everyone and as
all of us know buyers do have choice and
it's the product manager's job to make
it successful uh how to be successful
for the organization and most
organizations are also pivoted their
organization around products so that's
the another interesting dimension in
fact I was Consulting for one of the
multinational corporations who when I
was talking to their leaders they were
all saying that
I'm the owner of this product and almost
everyone was telling that I am the owner
of this product I'm the owner so I was
asking them what do you mean by you're
the owner of this product and they said
that okay I I manage end-to-end
responsibility for this product so so
including pnl then I was asking number
two manufactures who sells and who
that's the Matrix to organization but
it's my responsibility to ensure across
the Matrix to organization the it's
seamless and it's successful so multiple
products might be manufactured by the
same production line but each product
manager owns the full responsibility
until so it's becoming too complex at
such a senior level people are owning
products and are able to handle
end-to-end responsibility so that's the
sort of uh positioning product
management is having we can go to the
next slide please what
yeah
so as I mentioned they are completely
responsible they are right at the center
almost every aspect of the organization
revolves their own product management
today and not only from that point of
view I was even doing some bit of career
counseling for people and they were
interested in some sort of statistics
around how the salary benchmarks are and
we could see that product management
professional clearly outspokes many
other professions from a salary
benchmarking as well the year on year
increases that has come out in a recent
survey so that I think it's one of the
most sought after today careers for
people so I think rightly that you are
all interested in this particular area
and we are also excited about bringing
this sort of a program to all of you
because it's again an amalgamation of
many streams that we have been teaching
except directly that we are able to put
this program together we can kindly move
on to the next slide store
so the skills as I was mentioning to you
now look like product manager has to
have all these sort of skills whether
it's design thinking market research how
to understand user Behavior product Road
mapping
methodologies from agile to various
tools that are available in the market
to leadership mindset so or a growth
mindset also so almost
it's like having all the dimensions of
skills
program we are trying to do quite a bit
of Justice I would say which I will be
explaining as we go down this particular
slides as to how we are trying to cover
most of these aspects so if you can go
to the next slide let's do it
at this point we're going to run a poll
of the audience and if you are watching
on the streaming service you can put
A B C or D into your comments but this
is
a question about what's stopping you
from taking a program like this what has
what has stopped you passed from doing
that
so we'll run this Poll for another 20
seconds
this is live Poll for the audience that
is watching the replay so
please do answer this this is not uh
this is going going on live
foreign
responses from today
and here is the result I'm going to
share that with our uh audience on
WebEx
about 57 percent of people have said
that they haven't found a program that
will give them practical experience that
will let them confidently claim
that their product management experts so
with that we're going to return to the
replay
and here uh Dr Sullivan
tell us more about it
very interesting and uh so this
particular program what we have
conceived and put together actually uh
does not require
experience in product management so we
are starting grounds up
build your skills we assume that
Beyond two hours two years of experience
that you might have in any field it
doesn't matter you might be currently in
it you might be in manufacturing you
might be in sales it doesn't matter but
you are welcome to this particular
program because we will be assuming that
you have no sort of product management
EXP
and that's how all the sessions have
been uh
into this particular program so that way
you you can be rest assured that your
experience is not going to be in your
way of becoming a product manager
certified person
and the second one was about your
schedule and conveniently we have tried
to keep it
in the weekends three hours a day three
hours
because there'll be some amount of work
which will be required during the
weekdays as a preparatory material if
there is a session on a weekend and if
there is some reading that you might
have to do that might happen and towards
the end of the program there is going to
be a Capstone which we'll explain to you
there again you might have to work a bit
more but I think by then you will be so
excited about product management that it
should not be a constraint at all of
your spending more time on the Capstone
project so we'll explain to you how the
program is structured and how it is
getting executed so that you are able to
appreciate that uh in about
five hours per week
that you will be spending over the next
four to four and a half months you can
be comfortable comfortably saying in the
market that you have understood most of
the facets of product management and
also had sort of Hands-On through a
Capstone so all that is getting assured
through this particular program
so as we can move to the next slide
so existing product managers are also
welcome it's not that if you have a
product management certificate you
should not be joining because there are
certain things which might you might
find it very relevant and especially
what happens in product management which
I have seen is the learning that happens
from a cohort in terms of TPO learning
is quite High because each of them bring
in different experiences and when you
work in teams in your Capstone you will
find that the amount of learning that
you can leverage from each other is
going to be quite immense
so and aspiring product managers who
have two years of experience in any
field so they are also most welcome into
this particular program in fact most of
you I I assume that will be in the
second category where you will be
aspiring product managers
as we can go to the next slide
and again another poll
and this one is just basically to get a
feeling for how much
experience if you have in the workplace
this is not particular to product
management be any type of experience
we'll run this Poll for another 10
seconds
and three two one
here is the result
sharing with the WebEx audience
and this is a pretty even distribution
uh 30 percent of our audience has more
than 10 years of experience with the
levels of experience from
lower levels are distributed about 20
percent in each category so
the broad range of folks in today's
audience
so I think that's very nice and I saw
some questions pop up which was asking
uh
front Industries is it relevant for them
as well or is it not and I thought let
me explain to you that uh we are seeing
nominations come from almost every
sector whether it is financial education
manufacturing you you name it sales and
marketing because as I told you this is
a rounded sort of a profession and even
from an industry whether we are seeing
that retail
utilities we even have a member of the
legislative assembly participating in
this so it's a rules in public policy
and that person is also looking to
participate on this program so today
product management seems to be the
interest in the fancy of almost every
industry that is there so that way I
think you can rest assured that
irrespective of which industry because I
saw I'm in Aerospace would it be
relevant for me of course the Aerospace
is one of the most uh promising areas
where product management is relevant so
you'll find it absolutely applicable for
you one more question which popped up
was does it have any connection with PMI
certification just to reiterate PMI is
for project management it's not for
product management so project management
is about how do you use resources
quality and time in the most optimal
fashion is not to do with the customer
the requirement the needs and the sort
of product that you are going to be
designing and taking it to market with
the pricing and all so it's more about
execution so PMI comes in there and it's
nothing to do with product management
this is very different which I am going
to be now explaining to you what we are
covering in this program so if you can
just help me Steward go to the next
slide
yeah so
uh the way to read this particular slide
looks very complex is that we go from
the bottom to the top because the
program starts right at the bottom where
we are having an orientation
and uh introduction session which are
very short sessions they are not
actually the part of the program and
their short session just to bring
everyone to speed in terms of what the
what this particular course is about and
getting everyone to the same page so the
actual module start from why products
fail and some succeed that's where the
first module starts from there onwards
you will see that there are about 13
different modules each of them three
hours duration which are all structured
and if I can take the privilege of just
walking you through them I think it
covers things like product ideation and
strategy then it has the leadership and
growth mindset the value validation new
product development the feature
engineering
developing services and platforms which
is very different from products so how
do you really work on services and
platforms and then we get into
prototyping
getting to the life cycle management
systems thinking how do you create a
business model once you have everything
there how do you do a ux design and that
to using let's say neuro product design
which is one of the hottest topics today
that how does Neuroscience come into
product management and supports it and
then product roadmapping and
prioritization
and we have a separate session on tools
so where commonly used tools are also
taught to you so that
tried them out in specific areas for
example you will be finding that some of
these are going to be very very helpful
for you so the tools also will come in
very handy
there are 13 modules apart from the
tools module and then you also have
interestingly industry experts coming
and talking to you during the time of
this particular program
so we are going to have experts from
VMware Amazon Adobe Microsoft coming in
and sharing their experiences of how
they develop projects
so
and lastly the Capstone which is also
mentioned here
towards the end of the
program you will be having
a touch point where a project will be
given to each of you this will be again
by an industry expert who has designed
this product uh the projects capsule
project and that will ask you to use all
the learning that you have done across
the 13 modules and try it out in a real
life sort of a scenario
and there will be clear submissions that
will be asked from each of you which
will be evaluated and you will be having
one more touch point there will be two
touch points for capsule one more touch
point where they will give you some more
inputs or a feedback sort of a session
based on what you have submitted so
that means that even after we complete
all the theoretical and sort of
application sort of sessions you will
still be trying it out practice will be
there and therefore it's very very
comprehensive from learning and
application and also practice all three
dimensions of learning are going to be
given to you as part of this program so
that way it's very comprehensive and
also with the combination of the
industry experts it will be also be able
to see how these concepts are used
across other Industries so that's what I
wanted to explain to you about the
program so you'll find it extremely
interesting to go through that and the
uh just giving you some of the faculty
who might be doing some of these
sessions
of course one or two of them might
change as well as we go through and
depending on the interest that people
are showing so uh
you have Dr Christopher who is a head
and director for the Y campus they
actually coming into this program you
have Nick who's from Australia and he'll
be teaching you about the sort of neural
product management Concepts Dr Meadows
might just chip in for a small expert
lecture she possibly will do a video for
you and send it as a recording and so
she's one of our experts who's in our
Innovation Center head of the Innovation
so she might be chipping in with some
expert sort of a session
and uh the others shirish is from
Singapore so it's a global sort of A
Faculty which is what I wanted you to
understand so Nick is from Australia Dr
Chris is from Dubai campus she races
from Singapore so you'll have
uh the global faculty and today I have
the privilege of introducing you uh
Professor NADA to you
who's also one of our faculty and she's
based from our Dubai campus and uh
if you can go to the next slide this is
NADA for you very very eminent professor
in marketing and
has a rich experience in the corporate
side as well as you can see she was the
marketing manager at uh Royal Dutch
Shell
became a brand manager at Procter and
Gamble and Senior brand manager at
Colgate family
and the marketing director later on in
Morocco and she also teaches in Geneva
so rich experience from a Global
Perspective in a variety of subjects
that she has been teaching so today we
have a privilege of interacting with
Professor NADA so that she can uh it's a
free flow for her to
decide what she wants to talk to you
about because there are variety of
modules that she's going to be handling
in this particular program but some
elements of that she might want to share
with you all
and give you an explosion so that you
are more confident
on how to go forward with this
particular program
so with that let me turn it over to of
Sonata and all yours Professor welcome
to this session
thank you very much Sylvan for this
introduction it's a pleasure to be here
today with you uh to give more details
about the modules I'm going to be
teaching in this program uh of products
management which I find super
interesting and super Cutting Edge
somebody was asking in the chat and I
was looking and reading the comments I
have a lot of experience in a specific
domain uh how this will benefit from my
advice to this person is to go ahead and
look at the program look at the
components and look at the elements it
is true that when we are experienced in
an area we develop
um a lot of knowledge a lot of expertise
a lot of know-how but sometimes it's
very interesting to go back to uh first
of all learning the latest knowledge the
latest Technologies the latest processes
something more holistic the fact that we
have worked for so many years in an area
does not mean that we got proper
coaching or proper training at all
levels of what is required uh and
sometimes we are so
um busy with our day-to-day uh
obligations that we don't have time to
keep ourselves up to date as uh with
with what's happening the latest
Technologies the latest findings the
latest tools the latest skills uh the
other interesting things about learning
in this
context is uh all the interaction that
the participants are going to get with
their classmates uh all the comments
that they're going to be reading uh it's
not only going to be about one industry
but the exposure is immense in the sense
where they will get a chance to also
know the applications on various
Industries
so uh I I see that's there are a lot of
opportunities to um
learning and expanding the expertise in
this program and thinking of new ideas
to incorporate new things within our
day-to-day uh jobs so uh today I'm gonna
be giving you
um uh
an appetizer of uh what I will be
teaching in my modules for example so I
am responsible for module number seven
which is the value validation uh and
Justin if customers would pay and module
13 which is designing the business model
targeted marketing and market analysis
so as Selvin said uh I have uh worked in
this area I was myself a brand manager
so I had to manage several products
several Brands and to end uh that's how
I I got my my professional experience
um but I also uh did a lot of uh
supported startups uh with their new
product launched their product
management when I was
in Switzerland for the past 15 years
working at the University of Geneva so
um so let me let me double click a
little bit on the value validation and
testing if customers would pay uh so in
this module I will be supporting the
participants in really learning about
how to define product value
uh so I have been teaching Executives
for over uh 15 years now thank you I
believe almost 15 years and uh whenever
um
uh people are you know these Executives
come along in their projects and they
try to work on the new product
uh often they are so excited about their
the product the product feature that
they it's not their top of mind the uh
go into thinking about the value
proposition thinking about
um you know uh how is this uh products
going to be best perceived or best
served the needs of the target uh
customers so in this module the first
thing we're going to do is we're going
to learn a little bit about how do we
Define these
people that we would like to Target with
our products and then once we Define
them once we learn how to segment them
uh then we will identify uh what is the
best value proposition that we can offer
them
um to benefit their need and this is how
we can generate maximum return the best
way to uh have winning uh products is to
really assess this value proposition and
when we talk about value proposition we
really
to talk about the benefits and the costs
associated with adopting this product
and also we have to give our Target
customers a reason to choose our product
as opposed to
um competitors we do not exist in a
vacuum we are in 2022 as all of you know
uh competition is very high all the
areas have been explored already so
um there is less and less white space
available
this does not mean that we cannot launch
new highly successful products we see a
lot of startups coming in and disrupting
huge players in the industry for example
here in Dubai we are very proud to for
example always set with a beauty who is
[Music]
um
small American startup uh she's American
she's Iraqi now she lives in Dubai and
she had her startup Buddha Beauty in
makeup and and and and and the personal
care products uh that she launched with
five thousand dollars uh and uh with
this
um startup that was launched on Facebook
and now it's driving on YouTube on on
Instagram she really managed to eat her
from the big players such as map for
example who uh really had a lot of
budgets and our big multi-nationals
hiring
um a very expensive cheap marketing
officers she still managed to do it so
these are the kind of examples you will
be learning from uh in in these sessions
and and trying to really learn from them
and based on these examples we will
develop some highly relevant value
propositions
also in terms of value propositions we
will try to understand the different
dimensions of value so the functional
value the psychological value the
monetary value that the customer would
be getting from this uh proposition and
also learn how to assess the importance
of each of the values
the other thing we will be looking at is
uh also how does this stand versus
competition
so um
you will be looking at Point very points
of parity how are we similar to
competition how are we different from
competition how are we Superior so uh
these all these questions and all these
Frameworks will help us Define our
products value and make sure that uh we
have a winning proposition we have a
successful proposition
um the the number three reasons for uh
new products and new startups to fail is
offering products that do not have high
traction
it comes from not taking the touch we
look at the Target markets and the needs
and their needs and the value
propositions that we are offering
then in this module we will also cover
uh the various ways to validate this
value proposition uh through market
research
testing uh our value proposition and
seeing if our customers are really
willing to pay for it
and I've seen this I see this all the
time when I work with Executives on
projects is that they come to me
um and uh they're like oh I have this
great idea I believe it's going to be
successful
but I say okay but did you test it did
you validate it with your target you can
have the best idea and you believe it's
really Innovative and nobody has done it
before but if nobody is willing to pay
for it nobody perceives it as valuable
then it's not really worth much I'm
sorry to say
so usually what we do is that we do some
market research we do some markets
analysis we do fantastic and there are
many ways we can test
um a new value proposition depending on
where we are in our progression
so we can for example do a concept test
we're still thinking about the concept
and we don't yet have a prototype we can
test the concept and the value
proposition alone and get a sense of its
uh traction we can also test
um a prototype sometimes
startups would have a prototype where we
have uh some the product is not the
final
version it's similar to the final
version and we would like to go ahead
and test it and see uh uh how how
attractive it is uh and and validate it
with our target market and sometimes we
have a product uh and we are not sure
you know if we still need to tweak it uh
what do we need to change then what we
do is that we test as a pilot as a bear
so these are all options available when
it comes to market research and Analysis
the last learning objective which is so
the real focus of this module is going
to be defining the product value and
looking at the market research the third
learning objective is going to be the
third important so the focus is going to
be on the first two but we will look at
the resources uh which teams uh which
financial resources do we need to
deliver this product
so this is for uh the module number
seven
now let me move to uh the other module
I'm going to be teaching you
which is designing the business model
uh targeted marketing and Market
analytics so this module is uh later or
towards the end
and what this model does what this
module does is really introduce you to
the business model canvas and its
elements okay trying to really
articulate the various elements of your
business model
and look in at
[Music]
um
you know what's going on in the industry
understanding the the business model
canvas trying to understand its various
elements and also who's in this this
tool to
um assess the viability of your product
so
um a lot of startups again and companies
new products fail because they don't
have the right business model
they did not really assess the viability
so sometimes they run out of cash
sometimes uh they generate little
revenue and it's not enough to make them
cover their cost structure so over
depends on how much in
uh so if that the buckets are deep they
uh to to become viable but often now in
this day and age
um you have to go quickly you have to
fail fast and in order for us to avoid
uh dumping
a good product that has a good value and
is attractive we need to assess its
viability and we need to make sure that
we are on the safe side in terms of our
cost structure and terms of the
projected revenue streams that we will
be generating
so we will also in this module cover
some various marketing techniques uh so
how can we best Market it depending on
the budget we have uh so how can we best
Market it how can we uh best uh make it
reach
our targets markets and uh make our
target market adopt
this uh
so we will also be looking at the
various industry Trends it's very
important uh a lot of things are
happening we are in the postcode era uh
also
um now we are in an inflationary
economy so we have to make sure we
understand the trends
is coming uh Millennials are different
from our generation and we even have gen
Z now that's coming at the Forefront
that are completely digital native with
different needs so you want to make sure
also to talk to the audience because
that's the future uh so it is important
to keep track of these Trends to
understand the implications of inflation
on the industry you are targeting and to
have appropriate marketing techniques
and to develop the right strategy okay
and also what's very important is to
link your techniques to a clear Define
strategy okay and everybody has access
to marketing techniques everybody can go
uh for a Facebook campaign or an
Instagram campaign or a LinkedIn
campaign but how do you make sure that
you are designing techniques that will
are driven by a strategy that will
deliver the numbers that will deliver
clear objectives that are smart and uh
that are based on analytics and how
would you measure whether you are
successful or not so we will look at the
connection between these various
elements because often what happens and
I see this all the time uh with the
executive mbas that I teach uh have been
teaching for the past 15 years is that
we have a clear objective and then we
have a tendency to move quickly to
marketing tactics without really taking
the time to think about what is our
strategy and unfortunately when we are
tactics based tactics focused we would
find often ourselves doing firefighting
with competition
we have no clear strategy the moment
competition starts or dropping the price
or starts launching a new initiative we
get completely lost and we move all the
budgets into Tactical
tactical fights competition so these are
some of the things we'll be learning to
have a clear uh marketing plan that will
deliver the numbers which are the sales
and also the marketing objectives in
relation to the launch of this
products
all right so I think I uh that's that's
going to be all all for me Selvin if you
have any questions about these modules
uh feel free to uh ask a question in the
chat uh I'll be more happy to to answer
and I'm looking forward
um
in you attend the the point
thank you so much nada I think it was
very insightful how you articulated what
you will be covering in the modules and
I think as a requested any questions to
Nada please feel free to post it
and just to reiterate I think product
management is very very exciting in fact
just to give you an Insight today I was
reading about the circular
kidney which I think most of you are
quite now aware uh how it has created a
new product
it's very interesting for example we
have been always used to printing
whatever we have typed and no in A4
sheets there is a printer which is
actually Printing and that after we use
it we shred the paper or we tear it and
throw it away now a new device has come
where if you put the printed sheet you
get a white sheet outside
so which means you don't have to waste
paper once created so it's the circular
economy which is pushing that sort of a
Innovation the new product to come in
where you can keep reusing the paper as
many times as you want just by putting
it back into this machine so the
technique is so simple because just as
much as it's a ink that has been put on
the paper you can actually remove the
ink as well right so the technique is
simple but the idea behind it as to how
forces around circular economy are
pushing people to innovate and come up
with new products that's interesting and
that's all about product management how
do you and that's one of the interesting
topics which we are covering as you can
see ideation and how to come up with new
sort of products okay so I'm sure that
it's an exciting program and I'll now
request Naman to talk about more about
the program and what's in it for all of
you so over here I've seen a question
that was asked what I was presenting if
you want I can attempt to answer it
because I think it's a very interesting
so I think it's actually was asking how
the products management will help us to
build our own Venture if you want to
become an entrepreneur
so it's exactly a quick shoe with
everything that you need whether you are
you want to become an entrepreneur or
whether you're working in a company so
as most of you know all the companies
now are trying to be agile so the
entrepreneurship mindset is entering
within the organization Microsoft is
using that mindset to develop these
projects
um so this this program caters to both
and if you want to become an
entrepreneur this is exactly what you
need you need this design thinking
methodologies you need to get the soft
skills that this program is offering you
um as well and all these elements are
exactly what we use today uh in an
excessive way in our Executive MBA to
form future or to train uh future
entrepreneurs thank you
great thank you so much for that and now
I request Naman to take over from here
and explain more about the program
hello everyone
I'm Naman company so I'm not simply done
and the product manager for the program
uh so I just want to quickly uh Rock
everyone
through what are the key features of the
program how you can get into it and how
uh this product management program from
sp7 will help you up skill yourself and
grow in your careers so uh
so basically first of all we are uh in
comparison to uh
other product management programs we are
covering lives uh Hands-On uh training
and learning on product management tools
now these tools would be uh Google
analytics bits are widely used for
analytics across various uh top tier
firms then you would get Hands-On
training on some design tools obviously
product manager does overlap a lot with
uh when it comes to designing the
product which is very high level
designing obviously there are this is
not a design course per se but there's
always a high level knowledge in which
helps you in building mock-ups via sales
and also uh even if your product is not
a software product designing always
helps you in conceptualizing the product
in making sure it is equal then we'll
also be covering the next panel and jira
tools which will help you in uh
uh in your overall day-to-day activities
as a product manager
and there will be a live real life
networking and live sessions from
already existing product leaders who are
people working in Amazon Adobe Microsoft
VMware would be giving you real life
advice on how their Journey has been how
they have been into um management out
there company focuses on product
management how important is building a
product and how to grow the business
with the help of product
along with this at the end of the
program there will be a Capstone project
which is the overall aim of having the
Capstone project is uh
allowing you to apply the knowledge that
you have gained through a global recycle
things from SD gen and
the top tier instructors from simply not
wherein you will be working on a real
life case which has been carefully
curated and designed by products experts
from the industry this this is going to
give you live hands-on experience in
terms of how actual real life problems
are out there in terms of building a
product these problems
would also stand across different uh
domains and different uh
different facets of product management
along with this uh and I also want to
highlight the Capstone projects that we
have these are uh based on
for example problems from Facebook
problems from Netflix Tesla Instagram
Nike
product Managers from these companies
have faced such problems and these are
the actual problems which you would be
solving in Capstone project
and at the end of the program I was also
seeing a lot of folks were asking now
will there be any job of assistance
along with the program or not so there
will be a simply learned job assist
which will help you in landing future
roles as a product manager manager in
your career
and we also have a financing options uh
available for people who are
want to finance the program you can
you can like have it for just
as low as 5000 per month
going forward would you like to continue
or they want me to take over
go ahead
[Music]
and you can take it forward
so uh in terms of Eligibility you also
want to clarify uh there is no need to
have any prior product management
background
you could be from any domain could be
from software industry or could not be
from software industry it could be an
engineer you could be a designer you
could be um some application engineer
you could be working in an automobile
industry in fashion industry it is
proven for all and
you just need to have at least two years
of experience in any field
so at this point we'd like to ask if
you're
based on what you've seen in the replay
are you interested
in taking this program
we'll just leave this open for another
20 seconds
so uh almost 80 percent of our audience
today
are interested in taking this program so
this would be the right time for me to
share with you
how that works
I'm going to stop sharing the
pre-recorded video to reach the
end of that
and we will move into
live
I will share with you
how to enroll in the program so
and after this uh Arnold and I will take
your questions
answer them to a best of our ability so
to enroll in the program
very simple three-step process
you apply it ask us a simpleton.net
conjunction with SP Jane we review your
application verify your requirement
prerequisites
and then
we will issue you an admission
invitation if you qualify
the next cohort of the program starts
24th November with a program induction
orientation class and then the actual
coursework starts
11 December
so
we've shown the fees here for India and
rest of world
in India one lock fifty four thousand
eight seventy five
um
no interest financing as well as 51.41 a
month
rest of the world US dollars
two thousand one hundred dollars again
financing available as low as 175 a
month
we always remind people to ask their
employers about tuition reimbursement if
this is a program
that will uh help you in your current
position you may find that your company
is willing to help you with the cost so
for more assistance we'd ask you to
reach out to us at
ask us at simplylearn.net put that right
into the chat
so that you have that available
and then we'll move on to questions and
answers
so
that email address is now in the chat
and
all right Arnold uh you're on mute
yourself right I think I was on mute my
apologies yeah no worries
um
someone asked me asks uh if a fresher
can take this course
uh yes absolutely there are no
restrictions in terms of any uh limits
in terms of the eligibility anybody
who's interested in product management
and wishes to you know trans transit to
a product management career would be
more than happy to take this program up
and the amount of knowledge that they
will gain will be exponential so there
is no such Criterion that is set for
anybody which would restrict anybody to
not be a part of this program so yes
anybody and everybody who's interested
can be a part of this program
Abhishek asks how this is different from
scrum Alliance certification and I know
that criminal Alliance is
project management type of
discipline as opposed to a product
management want to comment on that
sure
um so let me give you a holistic
overview of how these two are very
interrelated to each other but
significantly different from each other
when we talk about uh you know scrum it
is particularly the idea of how you
manage small aspects of your product and
try to get them developed and rolled out
because you cannot completely develop
and you know release a complete product
feature into the market without breaking
it down into smaller segments or smaller
smaller pieces to be precise and the
idea of project and scrum is to help you
and your cross-functional teams
understand how exactly would you
prioritize the creation of different
features in your product and how would
that impact the audience to which it to
which the product is going to cater and
how would you prioritize that
functionality to be given to your end
audience so there is a similarity when
it comes to how you're going to plan
which part of the feature in the product
is going to be rolled out first what
comes next and so on and so forth and
that exactly is carried out by a process
as you mentioned called scrum and that
is something that is regularly repeated
on a cycle price basis it could be a
bi-monthly process it could be a
bi-weekly process depends on the kind of
complexity of the program or the the
product that you're developing
and the concept of scrum is to a to a
great extent used in the entire product
life cycle management when we start
ideating and we start to put down our
thoughts on paper and try to understand
how exactly are we going to develop this
product and give it birth and actually
take this to deployment once this is
completely ready end to end uh so
getting everything ready at one go
becomes very difficult because there are
a lot of nuances and a lot of teams that
are involved in the creation of that
product so taking it live on a
sequential basis at regular intervals by
launching it talking about it solving it
developing it via scrums is what exactly
the idea of management of the product
management is and it's a very important
aspect of how product manager Works in
these grounds to ensure that has he been
able to prioritize the right set of
features that have to be rolled out so
that they can eventually reach out the
audience at the right point of time so
they are they are internally related and
at the same time extinguishingly
different from each other
I have a question in the Q a from Manish
who asks uh does prototype mean MVP and
MVP of course is minimum viable product
um
I I I'll make a quick comment and I'll
let you address that I don't know but a
quick comment is that they don't
necessarily mean the same thing because
you might prototype something that isn't
quite the level of the minimum viable
product
um you might prototype it to test it out
before that but
certainly when you reach the level of
the MVP you probably want to prototype
that and do testing as well because
that's how you then determine how to
move beyond the minimum to commercially
viable products
our numbers do you have anything to add
to that
yes absolutely I think your balance to
it and just after that
um prototyping is you playing around
with your thoughts and trying to see
what works best and have you been able
to you know create your thoughts and
come up with a solution to the problem
that you're trying to solve and in MVP
as you rightly mentioned which stands
for minimal viable product should be
something that should be able to sustain
uh the entire requirement of the product
for which it has been built and it
should cater to three particular
parameters taking into consideration
whether the product is viable feasible
and desirable so considering these
parameters If the product has been able
to come up successfully and has been
able to satisfy these three major areas
then yes we would consider calling it an
MVP anything before that is what you
would create as a prototype prototype
does not have any Dimensions does not
have any verticals it is just you
playing on with your thoughts and trying
to bend them down or put them together
to come up with a solution that you feel
might lead to you might lead you to
creating an MVP
excellent
um she'll be asked can you tell more
about job assistance that's available
through this program
um so uh to give you a high level
overview I would not want to dig back
into the specifics of how exactly the
jogging systems works but yes with the
program uh you particularly look forward
to getting an understanding of how
exactly you can transition to a product
management role and how you can become a
successful product manager by
understanding what exactly is needed to
become successful product manager but
efficiently that is something that needs
to transition into something for which
you are looking forward to join the
program so that is why the job assistant
learns job assist program comes into
existence and with the job job
assistance program there are a couple of
things that we take into consideration
while we talk about the kind of job
assistance that will be provided as part
of the program uh we particularly
have uh you know are uh existence for
the purposes that we provide is you know
with a combination of a partner that we
work with which is called iron jobs and
high risk pay they provide us with the
uh benefit of preparing you with uh
building up your resume
excuse me
and helps you prepare with the kind of
questions that you will be expected to
you know be exposed to in case you get
an opportunity to crack an interview
with uh you know probable product
management role and understand the kind
of discussions that you might be looking
forward to uh happen in case you end up
having an interaction because
discussions around interviews that
happen with product management roles are
precisely discussions and not uh you
know one on just problem solving or
probably a brainstorming session as to
how you would be leading to creating a
successful product or how would you
actually lead to get to the corona core
reason for a product not being able to
successfully perform so these are more
interactive interviews that are you know
needed and so that the interviewer can
understand your mindset and the approach
that you're trying to apply to and that
is something that comes along with the
job assist program and that is how it is
going to assist you um in due course of
diamonds you've completed the entire
program
excellent thank you
um just the last couple of questions
that we have time for uh one is uh from
parag who is a mechanical engineering
background with over 18 years experience
um in diesel engine r d
how would a program like this be helpful
with somebody in a mechanical
engineering
so
um Prague I think we spoke on the chat
um I got an understanding that you come
with you know a solid amount of
experience in r d and I think that as I
also mentioned to a couple of queries
that I found on the chat earlier that
um whatever experience that you bring
onto the table with you while you're you
know transitioning to a role which does
require so many different verticals so
many different uh different teams that
work together to you know create a
successful product and with the kind of
experience that you bring from a segment
that has you know so much amount of
niche that focuses on Innovation
evangelization coming up with new ideas
trying to find out what would work the
best how will you be able to provide
that in a certain amount of time how
exactly have you been developing that
and how many of how many such products
have you created in the past and with
your tenure of experience I think the
plethora of information that you will
get onto uh the table while you
transition to a PM role and the kind of
success that I see that you will already
have got once you've transitioning is
that you have a strong sense of empathy
uh when you're trying to you know think
about it as to why that product would be
necessary because you already have
worked in that photo in the past and
thinking from a user mindset which is
something very very important as a
product manager because uh whenever you
try to develop something and you need to
First think that whether this is
something that the user will end up
using at all on the first place so these
are two things which I think that you
already have a strong hand on and that
is not restricted to your industry per
se that thought and knowledge and
approach can be applied to any industry
vertical uh be it manufacturing be it
e-commerce be it technology be it
education it's just how you empathize
for the end user to which you're
providing a solution to and that is
something that you've been doing for the
past 18 years all you have to do is
transition from thinking from a person
who is going to utilize your product
from a manufacturing industry standpoint
and start thinking about your user who
is particularly somebody who is going to
be using a e-commerce website or let's
say somebody who is probably going to be
in a department which is let's say
associated with the fnd or the food and
beverage industry so the user behavior
is just going to change but the point of
view that you will be trying to focus on
as to how I solve the problem is
something that you already have
expertise in and the only things that
you need to get a little bit of hand
holding is something that will anyways
be covered as part of the program
thank you
um
and last question Amit asks uh how do
you apply product management if you have
a I'm assuming you mean like because my
tool it's already in place
um I think it means a product that he's
already offering
um so if I'm assuming that correctly how
would you apply new product management
skills to a existing product
um so uh the best part about product
management
um is that no product can ever satisfy
the needs of the end user or the person
who's going to use the product because
the needs keeps on changing and they
keep on developing and that's why you
keep on making new products
um
let me give you a very relevant example
that everybody in the platform would be
able to relate to
um when we started with iPhone we had a
version that was uh probably 10 or 12
years back and when Steve Jobs had to
introduce that to the industry that was
the first of its kind that had been
introduced but that doesn't that didn't
stop Apple from creating more versions
of it and now we have iPhone 14
currently running in the industry and
they're selling successively so it's not
something that can restrict yourself to
at one point and that applies to every
product approach or every product that
has been launched into the market you
have to keep on developing it keep on
adding something new to it so that you
can continuously satisfy the end user as
well as try to be one step ahead of your
competition and that's exactly what is
the concept of something we call as
product Road mapping and that is what
exactly assumes also something that is
going to be covered in the program and
will give you an idea as to why this
development needs to continue
continuously happen it's like a cycle
that needs to go on unless you want your
product to become stagnant
and you know that's how you you know
some products into failing so yeah
that's that's something that is
important and while you're developing
something new for that product you need
to use a couple of tools uh a couple of
tools that you already mentioned and
that is what will be covered as part of
the program
yeah one of my favorite examples of that
is uh
in in the U.S market for video uh Home
Entertainment
uh there's a there used to be a chain of
stores called Blockbuster which would
offer you um rentals of videotapes and
then rentals of DVDs
um but they were physical stores you had
to go to them uh you had subscriptions
and that type of thing there's only one
left in the entire world
um and it's it's only open as a novelty
as there's really no need for it
absolute type of thing anymore uh
Netflix killed them and Blockbuster
never looked at the uh the concept of
streaming as first off the concept of
home delivery of DVD
um as the competition that they'd have
to worry about but
Netflix was brilliant in that they
developed home delivery of DVDs but
quickly moved on to the notion of well
streaming is going to be available and
let's develop that the their product has
evolved and their competitor whose
product was supposedly stable and
perfect
has disappeared so again if you've got a
product as
kind of correctly said
you can't let it stagnate you have to
adapt the world changing around you and
that's why product management skills and
tools are so very important for you but
with that I'm going to move on to finish
the webinar if I've missed your question
I apologize but we are kind of out of
time so
uh we'll try to um
get to those Maybe by email
but I want to ask one last
question what happened here I will um
share this last
question with our audience
so for those of you who said that you
were interested
uh in
signing up for the program how soon
would you like to do it
and we've always said that if this is
something that will
change your life and your career for the
better it's always worth doing sooner
than later
the next cohort of course starts a
little bit later this month with the
induction class and the classes starting
in December so
that's your next opportunity
two seconds I'll show you
answers here
okay
so 20 of you are interested in that next
opportunity which is great
um and for those of you who are looking
further down the road this program will
be here uh for the foreseeable future so
um please do keep in touch with us but
we recommend that you email ask us at
simplylearn.net
right away so that you
get your questions answered and
um get into the process or be a
on the mailing list if you want to do
this sometime in the future with that
I'm going to
um
thank you all for being here I want to
thank especially our knob for uh
patients and answering your questions so
expertly
and again thank you to all for being
here please do contact us at ask us at
simplylearn.net and I will put into the
chat right now a few other links
um to a
video that SP Jane produced about their
institution and
link to the program page so
take a quick look
in your chat right now
with those links
and with that that concludes our webinar
thank you very much
thank you so much guys